uh durant was third on the media vote
where giannis was number one embiid
third
third and second jason tatum
fourth fifth and fifth and you saw jimmy
butler's name on there
as well as far as the back court goes uh
bradley beal first across the board
kyrie irving was fourth by the media the
media actually had jalen brown
as a starter in the eastern media right
kyrie irving fourth
what media who gets a vote in that the
media pads are like 125 people
somewhere around the world 28 a game
shooting for over 53 percent from the
field
as a point guard or a shooting guard
like
come
you don't know who they had ahead of him
it doesn't matter it's not five people
four people
that should be ahead of a guy no he the
media had him fourth right
so they had three guys ahead of that
they had they had bradley beal
one and they had jalen brown second for
the other start
james harden third and then kyrie irving
that's not that's not outrageous
i mean all right there was a lot of talk
about jaylen brown maybe getting a start
there was some support for that he's
having a great year yeah he's having a
great year i think he's um
he is uh he's the only celtic that i
think is having a really good year and
he's one of my reserves which we will
which we will get to
in just a bit